Let's just look at this code
execution that we're talking about.
If the attacker actually guesses
our correct password, and
types that as input to the program,
login is going to be allowed.
What they're saying here is
the attacker doesn't have to do that,
doesn't have to guess the password,
the correct password.
So it's guessing some password,
might takes trying different
types of passwords and so on.
It gives a BadPassWd and
we don't have an all flow.
Because the BadPassWd here, if you look
at it, it's still three, four, seven,
nine, ten characters long
terminated by a null.
We still are good,
because we don't have an overflow.
And when we don't have an overflow, this
actually fits into the space we have for
the password string.
So, no overflow, and
it doesn't match, so
as a result the request
is going to be rejected.
So this is sort of the things you do.
You either find a password,
then you have access.
You can become that user and
do what that user is allowed to do.
Or you can try a password,
but you're not going to be successful
by just trying any password.
The chances are,
the password you type Is going to be, is
not going to match the user's password.
And match fails, login fails